hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for my
Doctor Who Q&A this week generally a lot
of questions about Clara as well as
what's gonna be going on to the
Christmas special so I'll try and
address everything there is still a big
mystery about whether or not Jenna
Coleman's leaving so it's always
possible that if she is leaving she
could still stay on for a couple
episodes in series 9 as they make a
transition to a new companion like they
did with Martha I do think that whatever
the story of the Christmas special is it
won't only address that they'll also be
a unique story like a one-off story just
like there normally is careful for
spoilers so if you haven't seen the
episode yet so let's get started
question number one
Jill EGS if the master had been saving
people's minds since humans first
developed concepts of the afterlife
why didn't call on the doctor already
know about 3w and do you think that
they'll bring Clara back for the
Christmas special yes just address that
yeah Clara I think is gonna come back
they'll at least address what is going
to be happening with her character I
don't think she'll be part of the
storyline that we saw in the trailer I
mean obviously Nick Frost Santa
character addressed her directly so I
think he'll be the connective tissue
between what's going on in the North
Pole with the monster and the clerestory
there are just so many things that they
still have to address with Danny pink
namely Orson pink you can't get his
grandson without him having a son or a
daughter it's possible that we could see
like a super prego Clara if the show
moves in real time it would be less than
nine months Strax kept going on and on
about fluid retention in the premiere
and they kept throwing the idea of
having children in cars faced all season
it just feels like Clara being pregnant
would be the most logical way to wrap
all those things up and it would be a
compelling reason for her to not travel
with the doctor anymore the doctor
already said no hanky panky on the
TARDIS just because he didn't want more
TARDIS babies like River technically you
would get another River Song type baby
if Clara was pregnant and continued to
travel on the TARDIS
just address the 3w question it could be
a situation where it's all in doctor
Chang's head like the master fooled him
into thinking that they were a public
company that did all those things that
he explained in his office with Clara of
the doctor the less likely explanation
is that the Masters changes to the
timeline just hadn't caught up with
Clara and the doctor yet I think the
most likely explanation is that the
master was fooling everyone and 3w
really was
as public of a company as dr. Chang
believed it to be question number two
killer cookie ass I don't understand why
Missy did not regenerate so I don't
think we're gonna get an official
explanation until the next time she
appears and I would be just amazed if
she appeared in the Christmas special I
don't think it's gonna be till sometime
during series 9 or even later than that
the best theories I've seen so far are
that the cyber Briggs gun transported
her somewhere else and that the doctor
transported her somewhere else with our
compact the instant before the Briggs
gun hit her when you look at her here
it's really like she's dematerializing
not exploding a normal cyber blaster
would have just stunned her or caused
her to regenerate so the other
possibility is that that is not the real
Missy and that is why she didn't
regenerate like it wasn't a true Time
Lord body I just think it was like a
life model decoy situation like Missy
somehow fooled them into thinking that
the person we saw standing in the
graveyard was the actual Missy when it
wasn't just to go against the cyber
break theory for a second I feel like
the salute moment was so sacred or meant
to be so sacred that Moffat wouldn't
take that back by explaining that the
cyber Briggs saved Missy so for now I'm
just choosing to believe that that
wasn't really Missy that was killed
question number three Salem asks did you
notice Clara's eyes in the opening
sequence yeah I actually think that that
was them paying off all the dr. Oswald
moments in series 8 they'd spent
multiple scenes in multiple episodes
with her either pretending to be the
doctor or just doing things that only
the doctor does it could be part of
something bigger but until we get more
information or Moffitt explains it in an
interview I'm just gonna think of it as
like a one-off thing just something fun
that they did question number four Brill
Chan asks do you think that the break is
totally blown up or is he flying around
in space now that would be totally
awesome if they did a cyber break story
with him just having adventures off on
his own
I think tumblr can definitely help out
there but in the official Canon I think
he's gone into cloud of cyber parts I
don't think he's coming back
question number five Mitchell asks do
you think that Missy gave the doctor the
correct coordinates for Gallifrey and he
was just forgetting it was in another
dimension yes I do think that's true but
also a number of other people in the
comments have pointed out that the
coordinates like the actual coordinates
that Missy gave him were the same
coordinates that the fourth doctor
during periods of Mars so when she said
Gallifrey is where it's always been
she was really being truthful question
number six drew ass what do you think
Nick Frost meant during the Christmas
trailer when he said it can't end like
that I think that he's just gonna force
the doctor to come clean with Claire
about Gallifrey and that car will come
clean about Danny pink I think they'll
have a moment that provides some real
closure for her time on Doctor Who
so you could say Santa is getting them
the gift of closure for Christmas which
is all a fan could ever ask for like I
said I feel like pregnant Clara would be
the best way to wrap that up question
number seven Chaz asks what do you think
about the controversy over people being
upset after the last episode yeah the
the don't cream Amy thing I thought that
was complete rubbish I usually ignore
stuff like that I think most of the
complaints were coming from inside the
UK but it happens in America all the
time
anytime something crazy happens on TV or
movie or in a book a small group of
people will always flip their and
scream at broadcasters anytime people
get upset like that online I always
picture the big mob from South Park
question number eight
Danny asks who is your favorite doctor
so I would say right now it's still Matt
Smith followed closely by David Tennant
I think it's still a little early in
Capaldi's run too late judgment on him
I'm gonna give him series 9 and then
I'll try and put him into context with
the other doctors I always try and keep
an open mind about new actors especially
the secondary ones like the Companions
as well as the guest actors none of them
are super super sacred to me I mean I
enjoy them all but usually I watch
Doctor Who hoping to feel happy in both
Matt Smith and David Tennant made me
feel pretty happy as opposed to
depressed or freaked out question number
nine dark Neko Studios asked how
possible is it for Sansa Nick Frost
to be an exiled Time Lord that would be
super crazy I don't think they're gonna
do that I mean he was able to knock on
the TARDIS door so he's special but I
think he'll be like a highly evolved
being a number of people in the comments
have pointed out that they think that
he's like a real Santa Claus like the
show is gonna say Santa is a real person
and that's who Nick Frost is gonna be
they kind of did it with Robin Hood but
I think that there'll be some sort of
timey wimey explanation where Santa is
like a highly evolved alien being and
Santa Claus at the same time or if Santa
will have been an alien the whole time
or something like
that but I don't think that he's gonna
turn out to be a Time Lord as awesome as
that would be question number 10
ultimate gaming ass is Michelle Gomez
Scottish or English yet there were a
whole bunch of people that asked about
missing Scottish accent just to answer
your question Michelle Gomez is from
Glasgow just like Peter Capaldi I think
part of the reason that Missy speaks
with a Scottish accent is because it
comes naturally to Michelle Gomez the
actress and on set they thought it
worked in the context of the character I
think that the master would choose a
Scottish accent just because she's
obsessed with the doctor or we can call
her the mistress I'm mixing pronouns a
lot but you get the idea the master of
the mistress same character based on the
first time we saw her a deep breath
though I think that the master
regenerated intimacy long before the
11th doctor regenerated into Scottish 12
so I'm just choosing to think of it as
like a little bit real life influenced a
little bit obsessive master character
thank you everyone that submitted
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do there's still a whole bunch of
questions left for the Christmas special
to answer so fingers crossed that
everything is wrapped up with a bow and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner raggedy girl you and that Amazon
gift card just be sure to message me on
my channel or Twitter or Facebook
somewhere for details just answer the
question about bonus videos between now
and the Christmas specials since we do
have about 7 weeks but I'm probably
gonna do next is like an early series 9
video for some things that I'm really
hoping to see also be sure to leave any
special requests you guys have for
videos in the comments but I will be
posting another bonus video this coming
Saturday I'll probably do at least 4 or
5 bonus videos between now and the
Christmas special and once Doctor Who is
over once the Christmas special is done
I'll be doing Sherlock videos for series
4 they will be filming the series for
Christmas special in January but they
won't be filming the actual episodes for
series 4 like the main episodes till
later in the year so lots of Sherlock
lots of Doctor Who stuff coming this
Christmas in January so get really
excited about that
right now you can click here for my
finale video and you click here for my
episode 11 video thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight